en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
situación que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 continuamos
llevándoles toda la información desde
nuestros hogares
soy valentina torres sánchez gracias por
acompañarme iniciamos este espacio
hablando de la candidata vacuna del
laboratorio estadounidense moderna
porque sus responsables indicaron que
tiene una efectividad del 90 y 4.5 por
ciento de acuerdo con los resultados
preliminares de la fase 3 de estudios
sobre worth mawston realmente es un hito
en la lucha contra la pandemia porque
demuestra que nuestra vacuna mrn a 1273
es capaz de prevenir el cob y 19
incluida la enfermedad severa en la
gente que la recibió entonces sí es un
hito tenemos mucho trabajo por delante
saber que la vacuna será efectiva es una
noticia grandiosa pero aún necesitamos
completar los procesos regulatorios que
incluyen finalizar los estudios generar
más datos y hacer seguimiento a la
seguridad
moderna indicó que planea tener 20
millones de dosis del fármaco para el
final de este año y producir entre
a mil millones de dosis en 2021 este es
el segundo fármaco del que se conoce un
porcentaje de efectividad tras lo
anunciado por facer y bayonne tec ahora
ambos medicamentos dependen de la
aprobación de emergencia de la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu con este permiso
el fármaco estará disponible pero de
manera limitada la comunidad científica
ha acogido la noticia y ha pedido a los
laboratorios que sean muy claros
respecto a toda la información
recolectada en los estudios para que las
personas puedan tener la confianza de
aplicarse estas vacunas de haute la
mayoría de las vacunas que se están
probando están basadas en dos dosis
típicamente con un intervalo de tres
semanas
así que como impactará eso en la
inmunidad de los pacientes si no vuelven
por la segunda dosis algunas personas
han dicho que a veces la vacunación se
siente como si te golpear una pelota de
vehículo eso pasa en unos días pero
tenemos que asegurarnos de explicarle a
la gente sobre cuál es el evento adverso
incluso si no es serio para que los
pacientes regresen
si veis jones temen ser de combate hasta
el momento 30.000 voluntarios han
participado en las pruebas adelantadas
por modernas esta vacuna al igual que la
de facer y bayón tech fue desarrollada
con arn mensajero muchas pequeñas piezas
de este material genético se inyectan en
el músculo de una persona y las células
musculares toman esas piezas y fabrican
proteínas del virus entonces el sistema
inmune las reconoce y genera una
respuesta que combate ese virus la
organización mundial de la salud celebró
los avances pero sigue mostrando cautela
ante los interrogantes que aún
permanecen de las vacunas tenemos que
esperar y ver cuál será la eficacia
final y el perfil de seguridad de esta
vacuna cuando se analicen todos los
datos después de que se alcancen su
criterio de valoración principal y
también tengan un seguimiento suficiente
de al menos dos meses de la mitad de los
participantes del ensayo para evaluar
efectos secundarios aún hay muchas
preguntas sobre la duración de la
protección el impacto en enfermedad
severa asimismo los efectos adversos
después de cierto periodo de tiempo y
cuando continúan los ensayos de estos
fármacos no sólo en eeuu y europa sino
también en china
quad se proyecta como el pionero en una
posible vacuna latinoamericana
veamos cómo van estas pruebas en el
informe de marina sardiña el candidato
vacunal es pues la carrera por la vacuna
contra el cob y 19 se libra también en
américa latina con cuba a la cabeza
mientras varios países latinoamericanos
aprueban vacunas experimentales
mundiales y compiten por acuerdos de
suministro con las principales
farmacéuticas la habana tiene en camino
dos vacunas propias que entrarán en la
fase 2 de ensayos clínicos antes de
final de año todos los esfuerzos están
para que en el año 2021 primer semestre
se pueda disponer de una vacuna que sea
efectiva que luego de él los anticuerpos
que no provoque reacciones adversas
importantes y en ese esfuerzo esta cuba
también puede significar muy importante
estos aportes que tendría cuba con su
vacuna para determinar los grupos
vulnerables en nuestros países de la
región la isla caribeña que tiene un
sólido historial de vacunas podría
convertirse en un importante proveedor
para los países de la región con sus dos
candidatos vacunales soberana 1 y sobre
favoreciendo a las naciones vecinas que
no tendrían que depender de las vacunas
occidentales para asegurarse las dosis y
vamos a finalizar este espacio fuera de
la tierra porque la nasa y spacex
lanzaron su segunda misión al espacio la
cru van ya en mayo ambas compañías
habían enviado en un hecho histórico la
demo de la primera misión en la que dos
astronautas de la nasa viajaron por
primera vez en la historia en una
cápsula desarrollada por una compañía
privada que fue spacex ahora esta es la
primera misión completamente operativa y
cuatro tripulantes llegaron hasta la
estación espacial internacional tras
despegar del suelo estadounidense y 27
horas de vuelo
la cápsula de esta misión fue llamada
resilience y llevó a tres
estadounidenses y un japonés
fue un viaje increíble y es muy
emocionante que este sea el inicio de
las misiones operacionales de rotación
de tripulación a la estación espacial
internacional desde la costa de florida
no puedo explicarle lo emocionados que
estábamos cuando el cohete despegó y las
últimas 27 horas
y se prevé que la nasa y spaces realicen
al menos cinco misiones más la próxima
está prevista para marzo de 2021 se
trata de un hecho revolucionario que
busca que compañías privadas participen
de la exploración espacial para luego
convertirse en pioneras del turismo
espacial mientras que la nasa se centra
en volver a llevar astronautas a la luna
así finalizamos esta crónica a ustedes
muchas gracias por su compañía continúen
con nosotros estos france24
[Música]